everything one does in life should be
for the interest of fun not fun merely
in the sense of play or leisure but fun
in the sense of deriving excitement and
enjoyment from life in general we must
alter our perspective of life in such a
way that prompts a movie like
observational experience of it a second
person perspective then enables us to
find entertainment and intrigue in both
the hardships and the joys of life it is
easy to slip into the feeling that life
is pointless when you neglect the
objective of fun when you ignore fun you
become hung up on destructive mindsets
and routines you work and worry and
adopt the delusion that fun will come at
the end of life but it won't your
journey will end sooner than later and
when it does you can't take anything
with you and all the fun you've been
waiting to have won't carry over we
can't store life away in the closet
hoping it will accrue in value life is
not like a vintage sports memorabilia
hat or Jersey you cannot wait 50 years
without touching it and then sell it for
profit
it only has any value when you wear and
enjoy it right now life crumbles of all
meaning when we become stuck to this
idea that someone will buy our life at
the end of it just because it is in mint
untouched condition
there will be no buyer and we will have
forgotten how to simply have fun and
laugh at the obscurity of it all imagine
life is just one day just like an actual
day if you wake up too late or not at
all you miss out on experiencing it and
you want to be awake for it as much as
you can wake up and understand that life
is not something to hide under the
covers from realize that life can be
serious but does not have to be arduous
take care of the tasks required to
function in the modern world but know
that they are temporary and not to be
solely identified with what you do in
life is far less relevant than how you
do the what in life there are
innumerable belief systems and ways of
living out the what in life but they all
bound by the same desired lifeforce of
fun and enjoyment you can either give
life a point by seeing it as an
incredible opportunity to experience the
reality of the world as your unique
consciousness embracing your profound
ability to play with life like a
malleable clay like substance or you can
live with your arms crossed and pout in
the corner your choice
[Music]